so some school leaders here in the
valley say they are fed up some notes
are being sent to parents maybe you got
one about a viral challenge on tick tock
that is encouraging students to steal or
damage things like soap dispensers
bianca holman joining us live this
morning a big enough deal that cram
middle school administrators actually
sent a letter to parents and they're
calling it a growing trend bianca good
morning
hey good morning john good morning
heather so it's called the devious licks
challenge and it's where students are
whether they're stealing or damaging
property it's all for attention it's
happening on tick-tock it's a viral
trend and administrators here at cram
middle school they've actually sent
letters to parents encouraging them to
talk with their student about this
criminal activity so the challenge has
become popular on tick tock kids record
themselves taking things like paper
towel dispensers speed limit signs or
even fire alarms or fire extinguishers
from school property those who do this
challenge well they're looking to gain
more followers gain attention of course
in a lick it's a straight it's a slang
term which means a successful theft the
principal here wants parents to talk
with their children about this trend
that's essentially incriminating
criminal activity and so the letter also
goes on to say that if those students
are caught there will be disciplinary
action and also school campus police
will be contacted so again a
conversation to have with your student
as you head out the door and drop them
off to school reporting live in north
las vegas bianca holmen 8 news now